when's the last time you heard the
phrase food insecurity in other words
food shortage if you live in America
you're thinking to yourself food
shortage in America I can go anywhere
fast food I don't have to worry about
this stuff why should I even spend time
learning about food insecurity here's
why because in the last 3 years when it
comes down to how many people can't find
their next meal according to world food
program 345 million people worldwide do
not know where their next meal is going
to come from so you may say what's the
big deal about 345 million here's what's
the big deal about it it's doubled not
in 20 years not in 10 years not in 5
years it's doubled in three years and
why is this important what does it have
to do with the price of fertilizer and
what does it take to make fertilizer
nitrogen phosphate and you have potach
who has that where do we buy that from
does this have to do anything with
bellus Russia Ukraine is that why this
is taking place are Wars hurting this
wait till you see some of this data here
but it's something you need to know
about and I'll give you the last thing
to be thinking about before we get into
the episode an article just came out a
couple days ago the most expensive Big
Mac meal you want to buy in America at a
Connecticut McDonald's it's over $18 the
combo ends up costing that person buying
it roughly $21 so you may want to learn
a little bit about this food insecurity
because what it takes to make it could
affect the states okay so if you get
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel let's
get right into it 70% of the world's
hungry people living in areas afflicted
by war and violence 70% now let's go a
little deeper since the beginning of the
Russian invasion of Ukraine in February
2022 Ukrainian exports of grain have
been severely disrupted for over 4
months Russian military vessels blocked
Ukrainian ports in the Black Sea between
July 22 and July 23 there was an
agreement between the United Nations
turkey and Russia to allow exports via a
safe Maritime humanitarian Corridor in
the Black Sea over a thousand ships full
of grain and other food stuffs left
Ukraine from three Ukrainian ports
during the implementation of the
initiative on July 17th of 2023 Russia
announc his decision to end the Black
Sea grain initiative so meaning they
will not let them out then you can then
all of a sudden they're like nope you
can't do this we're putting a stop to
this and this affects everybody because
they're one of the biggest exporters of
that product as you see here shortly
Russia and Ukraine together accounting
for one-third of world's Global Wei
trade 177% of global maze trade and
almost 75% of global sunflower oil trade
and prior to Russia's Invasion Ukraine
provided 11% of the world's wheat and
17% of corn so since the Invasion the
average price of shipping agriculture
products increased from $30 to $200 a
ton that's 7x in 2 years less than two
years 7x in less than two years February
24th 2023 US Department of Agriculture
estimates that exports of wheat in the
past 6 months have been approximately
37% lower than the prior year now this
is important because exporting matters
to us exporting matters there's certain
products we don't have in America that
we need from others right watch what
China is doing China is maintaining its
food sty stock Pals at a historical high
level why is China hoarding their stuff
why do they not want to play ball with
other people they're they're picking
things up but they're hoarding on
everything else the wfp predicts that by
2023 there will be a shortage of Wheat
and corn which are the two staple
products in the food supply chain the
reports also estimate that these Global
Food shortages will increase food prices
and even trigger a new Global recession
and if we look at the list of countries
with bans on food exports this is what
you would see Argentina on soybean oil
and soybean meal this band expires
December 31st Algeria you got pasta
wheat derivatives vegetable oil and
sugar Egypt you got vegetable oil you
got wheat flour oils lentils pasta beans
India's Got wheat Indonesia's got palm
oil and palm kernel oil Iran's got
potatoes eggplants tomatoes onion
kazakhstan's got wheat wheat flour this
keeps going over and all these other
places Kosovo turkey Ukraine Russia
which has got sugar sunflower wheat
meslin Rye uh barley Maz Serbia's got
wheat corn flour oil Tunisia Kuwait so
do you remember earli when we talked
about about the Black Sea grain
initiative between Russia and Ukraine
where it's like hey we got to get kind
of the exporting going again if you look
at this chart here this shows you what
was going on during Russia's invasion of
Ukraine look at the left and you'll see
green is grains and oil seeds and you'll
see blue is wheat look what happened to
the prices how quickly it went up from
220 all the way up to 360 or from 260
all the way up to 340 this is not good
for everybody else and then they come up
with a deal once they come up with the
deal what happens to the prices with the
Black Sea grain initiative it decreases
decreases decreases and what does Russia
do on July 17 2023 they end the
initiative if you look at Trends these
numbers should be going back up here
shortly as well because of the
initiative ending so look I've been in
the financial industry since 911 the day
before 911 and I've owned stocks bonds
mutual funds real estate crypto gold you
name it I've owned it but the one thing
that's very important part of my
portfolio all these years is gold I love
having a percentage of my netw worth in
gold that I have access to in case of
many different things a few facts you
need to know about gold number one the
gold market cap is 11.8 trillion since
2000 the compound annual growth rate for
gold has been
9.24% and during times of high inflation
3% plus has been
15.35% now those are just some numbers
for you but there's some other benefits
to add gold to your portfolio number one
hedge against inflation number two
results showed recently that 93% of Cal
banks are working on a cbdc so this
means what that could be a manipulated
currency that they own if you own gold
it's a non- duplicatable asset you're
now hedging against cbdc taking place
number three a potential cyber threat if
it happens you don't have access to your
money you don't have access to your
accounts where you have access to your
hard physical gold number four is
anonymous no one knows you have that
gold and last but not least
diversification that's why we chose to
work with our new sponsor American
Harford gold if you have retirement
funds that you cannot afford to lose
American Harford gold will ship physical
gold or silver directly to your door
also if you have retirement funds that
you can't afford to lose now is the time
to call American Harford gold a precious
metal dealer you can trust they have the
finest products amazing customer service
and a buyback commitment they've earned
a festar rating from thousands of
reviews and an A+ from the Better
Business Bureau tell them I send you and
they'll send you up to $5,000 worth of
free silver on your first order so click
on a link in the description or call
866939 6984 again
6984 so on top of that the other thing
we need to look at is fertilizer price
whyer price of fertilizers going up why
do many farmers in America why can't
they afford to buy fertilizers to
produce more food they need that if they
don't have fertilizer they can't
producer so where's the hold up look at
this chart here look at pricing 2019
less than 100 2020 less than 30 40 bucks
2021 there was moments it hits super
super low 2022 and then today
157 is what we're looking at compared to
where we were before and these prices
are not necessarily slowing down anytime
soon so where does fertilizer come from
one is nitrogen which is primarily
produced in the US it only takes natural
gas and we've got plenty of it says rule
adding that there are significant
nitrogen production plant scattered
throughout the Midwest Southern Plains
and Gul Coast areas so one way to see it
is it's got a correlation with gas
prices natural gas prices if gas prices
go up nitrogen is going to go up because
they kind of correlate with each other
so you may say Pat who cares if we can
do it ourselves why are we wor about
nitrogen well I'm just telling you
that's one area we're okay with because
if you look at these charts here here's
what you'll notice China's first by mile
then it's uh St India Russia Indonesia
Egypt Canada Pakistan Iran and others so
let's look at the second one which is
phosphate the majority comes from
Florida with a small volume imported
from Saudi Arabia Israel and Jordan
counterveiling duties on Morocco and
Russia have slowed imports from those
countries and if we look at the leaders
bulletin on phosphate here's what you'll
notice China is first us and India
pretty much High then it's Russia
Morocco Brazil Saudi Arabia however when
we look at potach this is the problem
90% of the poach that's used in the
midwest comes from Canada on rail cars
only three countries in the world have
significant amounts of potach Canada
Russia and belus matter of fact if you
look at the leaders bulletin here here's
what it looks like number one is Canada
then it's China then Russia then belus
then Germany Israel Jordan Chile La
Spain on some list we're 11th on some
15th on some 13th but we're not even the
top 10 so notice the chart I just showed
you it shows China as second right but
if we go to 2021 right before the war
look what China looked like on this
chart here this is 2021 number first
place is Canada then it's Russia then
it's Belarus then it's China what's the
problem Belarus and Russia ain't doing
anything right now because of the war so
that's why China just boom bumps the
other two out and goes to second place
this is why the Russia Ukraine is
causing food insecurity in different
parts of the world so now this gets you
thinking about Farmers Finance is on the
line because at the end of the day they
need to get to work they need to be able
to make money if there's no incentive
for them why are they going to do what
they're going to do and they need money
to go buy this stuff to produce what
they're producing right a report from
the University of Missouri found that
the net farm income in the state is
projected to decrease by 14% this year
and the US Department of Agriculture
anticipates National farm income to Fall
by 19% meanwhile Farmers input cost have
increased you ready since 2020 55% it's
a lot of money 55 percent it's increased
so to break down that increase here's
what it looks like fertilizer accounts
for about a third of those annual cost
and it now costs Farmers nearly 73% more
than it did in 2020 but Farmers continue
to buy because they don't have a choice
it offers a good return on investment
said Ray Massie a professor in mu's
College of Agriculture food and natural
resources so if you're watching they
saying man these guys are getting killed
in America but that's because they have
the dollar imagine other countries where
their currency is getting devalued month
after month after imagine what they're
dealing with their numbers are not 73%
it's much more than 73% this is in
America we're talking about so the
second factor for food insecurity is
drought South America is experiencing a
severe drought for the third consecutive
year the worst in a century primarily
due to the lania phenomenon that has
persisted since 2020 the countries most
affected are those produce a significant
amount of food for the world Argentina
Brazil Paraguay Uruguay in 2021 these
four countries account for approximately
133% of the global food and fiber
exports and they lead the commercial
ation of soybean soybean meal and pallet
soybean oil Frozen cellulose cane sugar
poultry and coffee and account for
significant share of the global supply
of wheat fish fillets pork chilled beef
wine fruits and fruit juice next factor
which we love but it's a problem why
just in time you've heard of just in
time before is a great thing but there's
some problems behind it let me explain a
justtin Time inventory system is a
management strategy that has a company
receive Goods as close as possible to
when they are actually needed this
inventory system minimises inventory and
increases efficiency this allows
manufacturers to not be left with
unwanted inventory if an order is
canceled or not fulfilled for justtin
Time Manufacturing to succeed companies
must have steady production glitch-free
plan machinery and reliable suppliers
look there's a lot of Pros obviously
it's got a lot more Pros than cons but
when when we have an inventory issue or
ships are getting stuck at Panama Canal
cuz they have problems or it's going to
take long this is problematic for that
and that's the season today so adjusting
time is great when everything is moving
smoothly it's not doing it today so look
final thoughts on this topic here am I
sitting here telling you to go you know
stockpile a bunch of food and just kind
of be worried about the world coming to
an end us is probably going to be the
last country that's going to you know
feel the residual effects of this but
should you be prepared for it yeah
probably I've been in the insurance
industry for over 20 years everything to
me is in case buying insurance policy in
case auto insurance policy in case all
of these things are in case water Dy
food canned food look at the Expressions
there's plenty of companies that offer
you to have the stuff in case something
were to happen if you can't afford to do
that you ought to consider doing that
it'll be a long time till us gets
affected by this monetarily we will be
but in a way where you're going to be
not knowing how to find your next meal
not going to happen anytime soon this
States if you got value out of this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel one thing that gives me a
lot of confident and about the future it
may not be a concept you know a lot
about maybe you've not heard a lot about
it musk's brother was participating in
this thing it's called vertical farming
if you've never seen a video we did on
vertical farming click you to watch it
take care everybody bye-bye bye-bye
n